to another controversial topic it's
which I am no stranger and it's no
exaggeration when I say there are a few
issues as divisive as the one I'm about
to raise next all over the world statues
are coming down in just the last couple
of weeks
New York has removed from Central Park
the statue of the doctor who tortured
enslaved black women India has brought
down Lenin and Canadians have defaced
statues of Queen Victoria in Britain
Bristol has agreed to rename its famous
music hall removing the name of Edward
Colston one of the nation's most
prolific slave traders now it's time to
take a long hard look at our the hugely
problematic figures we continue to
glorify such as Horatio Nelson
Nesselrode and yes Winston Churchill I'm
not saying we should necessarily bring
them down take a deep breath everyone
all options should be on the table as
the global movement to requestion our
so-called heroes shows the thing that's
clear is this doing nothing burying our
heads in the sand and hoping this debate
will go away
it's simply no longer an option I really
like you but I wonder if I can remind
you some words you wrote concerning
Britta ladies do Britain we have moved
on from this era no more than the u.s.
from hits slavery and segregationist
past the difference is that America is
now in the midst of a frenzied debate on
what to do about it
whereas Britain in our inertia arrogance
and intellectual laziness is not likely
to why do you stay in this country if
you take such offense when you see
Nelson's column if you take such offense
when you hear Winston Churchill's name
who I would argue if in the unlikely
event that anybody want to have a poll I
would say probably 80 to 90% of people
would say that Winston Churchill did a
good thing I'm delighted that I see you
at these Thursday on delighted you up to
Stanford but if it offends you so much
how do you manage to stay here I find
that a really strange thing to say
there's nothing of Britain that bothers
you sure but I don't believe in an
option tree this and the reason why I
rate was critique that not so much it's
Britain it
because I care about this country I
actually care about our honesty our
ability to move forward into a
progressive future I care about that
otherwise I would just leave it how is
it honest to decide to bring down
Nelson's column or to do away with the
church or war room or to change the name
of a concept is that the biggest problem
that people who have non-white people
have in Bristol the name of the Town
Hall or the concert hall or whatever it
is that's their biggest problem actually
it is a big know why Bristol and I'm
concerned about Colston Hall as the
councillor in Bristol I was talking to
recently called Cleo Lake who is of West
Indian heritage and her school was named
after Coulston and every day they have
this celebration where they celebrate
Colston range every day every year they
have a big costume day sorry that would
be that would be a lot well even I might
[Laughter]
now when she found out the history she
felt it to her core and she raised it
with her teachers let me finish why do
we glorify this man he was the kind of
person who sold an inflation for our
yield too much before and that affected
that affected her core it affects her
education it affected her confidence
before IU that was I would imagine your
supporter stretches to Gandhi
necessarily Donna which is about my
months when they've removed Chandi we
happy with stature it's funny you should
say that because I made a documentary in
which we questioned Elsa Mandela saying
we should be debating the way we look at
history so I'm not saying only white men
bad things we never talked about I've
been waiting patiently we only talk
about well I mean I'm really curious
because let's take Churchill I mean you
know obviously a lot of the controversy
around Churchill's historical record
applies to what he did in South Asia
with the Bengali famine and so on and so
forth and I don't think it's anyone here
is suggesting that we remove references
to that in history I think the question
is when looking at historical figures
what we're celebrating about them for
example if they happen to have saved our
very civilization there may be something
worth celebrating for what I'm really
confused that happy having you know
coming from the heritage that should be
offended at Churchill's record in South
Asia
I can recognize he's
our country what I'm really confused at
it's when we spoke about Winnie Mandela
and I raised the issue of the fact that
she was a fan of necklacing a fan of
Burgess explained wouldn't people
burning people to death for on the mere
accusation that they were collaborators
in the shanty towns in South Africa you
were very happy to not only argue in her
defense but write a column defending her
legacy is somebody that fought a party
like thing you've explained it before so
allow me to allow me to allow me to tell
you why I have a problem with your
explanation because that'll be more
concise you can respond to it you talked
about power structures and how you're
about tearing down power but actually in
South Africa Winnie Mandela had all the
power and those people she burned to
death had no power no defense she was
irrational about the fact that she was
burning people to death because this is
exactly what we're talking about and
then Carole you will come in this is
from a documentary I've made very
subject which is going out on channel 4
next week this is probably the place
where you can best see how Britain
thinks about its military history over
the last 100 years it's the great
glorious Imperial history
what is interesting I think is how
unquestioning it is there's a wee one
here's the monuments good for us there's
no mention of the victims on the other
side and there's no thought of who
caused all this that is not some loony
lefty that's Neil MacGregor so there's
and historians agree that we have been
raised a huge couldn't be a reminder of
our past good and bad let's talk you
know briefly about you know and statutes
are there they're not always built to
comfort or console or to honor if it can
it can be a salutary warning though you
know there's nothing about the
Confederacy that was noble its raison
d'être was slavery but there is
something there was something very noble
and necessary about a free people
preserving its history and
knowing who they are where they come
from and how they should be living now
and I think that's really important
statues don't always glorify people
however in the case of Churchill in the
case of Nelson I think they absolutely
should and I think there's an excess
eighteen ninety percent of people in
this country would so so but I just I
don't I think some of the Confederate
statue let me can I just read your quote
Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. who said in
1884 he said I believe from the bottom
of my heart that our Memorial halls
statues tablets tattered flags are worth
more to our young people by way of
chastening and inspiration than the
monuments of another hundred years of
peaceful life could ever be I think
that's absolutely true with statue
doesn't have to be pulled out it can be
there's a change the key to I'm saying
if we say this week is just cuz I feel
like you both have said something and I
haven't had a chance to correct it
talking about is correcting the record
right so magic usually they're not you
know most people know the history magic
mentions the Bengal famine coming in
rich you cannot correct and change the
changes it's the change and what to say
about it we don't know about the part in
Britain say they don't know about the
part that's what the point the point is
is that this is where we are this is how
we have got to the point we are we can't
go back and delete and correct norms and
today's morals and today's thinking no
you're not you're saying that we have to
make the past appropriate absolutely yes
you are not saying we must version the
fact that we are working on a pedestal
man that I know we now find
reprehensible or even in reading it's
because we're looking at their parts now
listen if we talk about moving the war
and I can just say we're just the thing
opposite of what my argument is just
finish the point my point is amiss I
know deeply I am as liberal as the next
man I find this deeply upsetting and
also almost insulting no I'm not and I
fear that you're taking this country
down the path of when Isis goes into
power mirror and
temples goes through round pages through
museums or like Mo's or like book
threats and it in the umpire destroying
people statues in history decide just
because a culture has some unwelcome
baggage that you dump the baggage
because it's no longer useful on your
journey now I want to say something
right first of all I'm not saying and I
said clean my intro we should
necessarily take them down this is what
I want a debate and the reason I want
those because we don't have it Rachel
and the real reason this is not a I am
the opposite of trying to erase our
history I want us to know our history so
when we look at Churchill I would like
people to know about using aerial
policing and mesopotamian not
distinguishing between civilians and I
would like about Nelson I want us to
remember the Napoleonic Wars I want to
remember the existential victory against
the frame only no.15 this is about
bringing we don't suppose there seems to
be a reasonable way forward here if what
I'm hearing you say now is about
education let's talk about the
curriculum and what's being taught in
schools and a multi-dimensional approach
to history which is fantastic let's not
talk about tearing statues down and also
actually in terms of statues what they
did in Oxford with Rhodes there's
another way forward as an alternative
here as well we can leave the original
statues up and there's plenty of space
in the Streatley statute of limitations
has run out on the statues debate we
move